let's go King unpretty there's about 98
players about an 1,800 average rating
let's roll quick wins is the idea quick
wins pre moves time burners you name it
all that fun stuff is gonna happen
isn't it I was just trying to Castle
queenside yeah let's Castle queenside
you know you want a Castle queenside
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa quick resigner
quick resigned I just got the Queen
uh-huh
come on yes back to tournament - oh this
is the guy that gave me in back-to-back
beatings man Alva Alva for sure watch
out for that you know what I can start
talking about a bit more trap wise watch
out for the Siberian the Siberian trap
now I could uh oh
that's the anti fishing pole no I'm
winning a piece no not a peace upon you
know what a minute you know what I meant
whenever I fumble like that and say say
that sort of stuff boom boom look out
look out
cook the bishop very similar to what
Noah's Ark everybody knows about Noah's
Ark right Forks tricks tricks and forks
every we're gonna come here I want to
watch over this pond it's a little scary
Oh what is the story with that what's
the story what is that story can
somebody let me know stop it
what did I do to deserve that okay my
queen has to let's come here or here
let's go here make up your mind what are
you doing clean here she's gonna run
away scared no she's not here we go
juicy squares right here on f3 juicy
squares Forks deadly forks
deadly force here hitting the whole
family potentially let's go for this one
it's a
I think it's better is it better
go there yes it's me
quick me quick mate six I was being
sneaky a bunch of sixes and a five Tony
Tony why did I say that like that
let's go stay focused here who cares
about the name play chess what you're
talking you're talking chase the night
away he must be scared he must be scared
looking for tricks making to threat
Knight takes Knight is not good natan -
uh-oh uh-oh Queen here mate - threat
time partner for anything it's a mate -
I could be fancy about if I wanted to be
made with the bishop or the queen they
resigned back to tournament 1200 man can
I get a little bit of a cushion maybe
could there be a cushion please can I
get a cushion not for my seat I want a
point lead a point lead cushion let's go
night um H pond you know you want to
play what is my opponent looking for oh
they're getting a piece now they're not
let's go each file move your pawns stop
oh stop the tricky Knights I'm on the
Queen they have to be scared at this
point right Oh got to do this I think
now here I have this covered there's no
night here okay right here get my Bishop
my rook say what you mean to say ah I'd
say what you mean to say what did you
really mean to say right there just take
here maybe I like retaining this pawns
flexibility let's come here back the
bishop up bishop here
get rid of your LightSquared bishop
plant upon on h3 and look for me you
catch that that's what I'm looking to do
oh oh are they scared they might be
scared
give a check making one threat right
here you're making one they're gonna see
it they're gonna see it right oh they're
not gonna see it that's me
quick mate back to tournament 2012 12 11
all right let's roll Yvonne mmm let's go
here space space is where it's at
give me the space the bishop doesn't
can't do anything over here now is the
bishop in and give me a check yes he is
I have a nice Center just Castle just
castle I didn't even need to do that
knight move let's come over here all the
bishops dead cook the bishop it's gonna
grab here let's back up Bishop Bishop a6
I want to get that night out of there
Bishop a six-night be three if not
Bishop a 683 I have this there's a drop
missed it they might resign dropped
piece why did I do that I shouldn't have
done that let's come here I want to get
to e5 take and I get to e5 let's just do
this lock it up now I shouldn't have
done that
now this prong could push now this
bishop has a future I should've done
that night here I got to stop the
pressure on this diagonal
how about Bishop to g7 then I don't have
to worry about a rook on the G file
let's get over here King f2 I could be
playing okay the bishop the the rook is
cut off from the action now King F 2
instead of Castle maybe Go Go Go Go this
game is taking forever
all right here can I get this pawn I
want to get rid of the light-square
bishop I think right squared bishop
sneak into f7 let's draw another rook
here maybe okay now it's with the tempo
woohoo a little scary over here let's
come over here I want to get an f7 and
then d6 I have 7 d6
man mm-hmm clean takes or something I
have that with my queen they don't have
any time I should have been just doing
time burners back to tournament 30 30 24
20 23 minutes remaining
okay let's roll here can I get a quick
kill a quicker kill my computer's going
crazier than normal that bothers me
stop the tricky night on b5 you know
what's happening you know it's happening
here you haven't had my fill Queen c2
you know you want to do Queen c2
fishing-pole siberian like traps
everywhere free night you know you want
to take him he's juicy juicy night on g4
they're chewing they're chewing clock
here clock you're gonna stop with these
things
I got a stop he needs to come to an end
you can't keep talking like this you
can't keep talking yourself like that
okay I got to undermine this oh no I'm
in trouble I'm in big trouble
no not weaseled out of that one give me
that dark square Bishop give me that
dark square Bishop get out of there
Queen there we go
dark square control g5 uh come over here
give me the g5 the Bishop's gonna give
it check should I be nervous
maybe maybe let's let's do this
Knight right there isn't isn't a bug is
it Queen right here Bishop on c6 that's
where I want to be get here Bishop Queen
here grab this pawn give me the g file
why'd I do that I should just taken or
something oh no no guard they don't have
any time oh I thought it was me that
didn't have any time for a second
thought tenths of seconds
okay here we go I'm the breed with the
the disney/pixar thing Geary's giri
something who knows what I'm talking
about where that guy plays against
himself the old man see that video look
it up chess Pixar you'll see an old man
playing against an old man here we go
it's being lodged it's being launched
I'm the breed already knows this oh I'm
the breed oh oh man it's there again
isn't it it's happening again
again sneaking in dangerous land right
here dangerous land let's try this clean
I'm gonna take and swing over to the
h-file I just want to take that Jeep on
maybe it's better to do that yeah just
um let's go here get to f6 can I get to
f6
this is made isn't it paan takes
discovered checkmate otherwise here no
no no I right here was made it's a mate
next move never mind they resigned back
to term in 56 56 42:32 less than 20 less
than 20 all right here we go clean c7
come on the bishop they missed it they
might resign looking to resign then they
play on they should resign power
suggestion right oh they should resign
right pieces are falling are they gonna
resign kitchen sink kitchen sink I'm
getting kitchen sink right here oh man
pieces are falling everywhere they
resigned back to tournament Oh
seventy two forty two forty two less
than twenty nineteen and change
king of pirates no your knight does not
move like that
the Queen's running home Queen is
running home let's take this and then
pin Queen psych now my queen should be
here I think castle let's try this I
want to get on this diagonal dark square
Bishop Knight belongs right here I think
for starters that's checked that's check
come over here right here let's go and
see five where is the main where is that
maid I want to get right here right here
Oh am i lagging my lagging lagging
lagging lagging watch out for the tricky
Knight never Queen trade you could take
that pawn no she can't where is the King
position you take that pawn King
position where are you at oh that pounds
gonna be targeted targeted I'm in
trouble I'm in trouble
I am in trouble the pounds gonna push
and I sneak in here pawn push where are
we supposed to go here my king wants to
be over here and then this pawn break in
the center
where are we supposed to go I just
dropped a pond right here pond break in
the center is that route gonna be out of
play that ponds gonna fall isn't it
I get that pond where is the main
where's the main it's perpetual isn't it
zigzag
game drawn by repetition that was so
tight I was holding my breath again
David Blaine mode engaged I thought I
lost that time than I thought he lost
that time
regroup focused here you're getting
dizzy right now that's what happens if
you hold your breath playing 1-minute
war zones don't ever hold your breath
like that again
why do you still do that have answers to
these questions I was ready to take
Queen takes pawn right there watch out
for trickiness everywhere take my bishop
No oh that would have been a disaster
wouldn't take a pond that was a free
pawn aah take free stuff my queen is
close to trapped
what's the clock situation regroup here
just give a pawn back to open the
position up for my bishop please okay
maybe I don't want to trade Queens let's
try this let's try of e6000 tit it's
winning stuff right here and then here
there's no tricky checks oh the rook is
on my bishop I missed that one
okay oh man let's stay active where are
the tricks I need a pig on the second
no Queen trade I can maybe get some pigs
still more pigs pig pig pig pig pig
alert I'm on the rope I'm on the road
I'm on the rope oh-oh-oh-oh deflection
deflection time there's only 10 seconds
Queen takes I take this give a check run
here it's safe here is it safe here over
here over here pivot squares pivot
squares where you at time situation
where we have what do they
you have this pond more checks check
check check everywhere just move quick
they're down on time back to tournament
ninety ninety seventy nine less than
fifteen it feels like I've been playing
for an hour oh this is only fifteen
minutes this is so intense I'm not
complaining I'm really not that's just I
can't help it I can't help it these are
the things that just it just happens
like this okay it just happens like this
okay so we're gonna block a check and
we're gonna get casted soon before you
get killed
how are they gonna defend are they gonna
defend okay let's go h-file lets castle
I was just gonna do g4 right away I
really wanted to do g4 Oh watch out
dangerous stuff happens soon I was gonna
take here but if this is just a free
piece watch out watch out f6 take here
bad stuff happens let's do this first
where's the mate I just got my bishop
why'd I do that I shouldn't have done
that that Queen f4 move oh I dropped a
piece why did I do this what's the
material count I'm dropping this pawned
this pawn has hit so many times oh no I
just want to trade can we trade please
are they gonna really take that pawn
don't take that pawn please don't take
that pawn come over here isn't okay
oh let's come over somewhere here just
take my rook I can't let you crash
through on c3 I was fearing the worst oh
this this one this one's gonna hurt if I
lose
what's the clock situation they didn't
take it oh hang on hang on get out of
tricks man this is dangerous dangerous
dangerous dangerous dangerous don't ever
play like this don't do it I just want
the Queen's to come off can we get the
Queen's off clock situation
I gotta go here no right here I gotta
throw in a check oh they're being sneaky
do they have time what's the plan oh man
I'm holding my breath again I'm the
breed again oh man
relax it's gonna be okay it's only a
chess game it's only a chess game what's
the worst that can happen what's the
worst that can happen you could get hit
with a stray bullet
stray bullet can hit you at any moment
oh man I'm playing dizzy right now you
playing dizzy these games are just way
too tight way too tight let's get
rolling beep on you know you want to
play okay let's get to d3o okay that
could be okay okay be a pain night
that's your job be a pain dark square
bishop let's get off whoa the exchange
given up the exchange
come on Knight you know where you belong
no no no no no let's guard that pond
he's important oh very nice
I like that move okay can I get this
pond whoa okay where are the tricks
gotta break these guys up or something
clean here I'm on this pond I was gonna
go here but there's a fork take this
pine my Queens very active now she's on
the night and I'm on the bishop I'm on
the bishop Oh trouble big trouble we
might have resignation right here but we
have 12 seconds remaining back to term
at 1:30 170 160 130 ah there's only ten
minutes remaining
Eugene Locke here we go
Eve for my opponent disconnected wait a
second
do I get some free
points isn't that the new rule or
something if your opponent doesn't start
or something is disconnected don't you
get the points come on give me the
points give me the points hit me with
the points what's going on here
you can't see it on the screen but just
above it you might see a little shadow
or something
in the meantime I'm dropping you know I
might be dropping back out of confetti
land soon I won't get top three this is
only a 10 pointer I think because the
points aren't doubled I thought this was
gonna be um if your opponent doesn't
move then what you get the points you
get to double the points and then you
know what am I talking about
let's go to game that's going on maybe
games that are going on right here right
here who's a tight one this is a tight
one no it's not blacks up a queen my
opponents lost okay I only got 10 points
for that back to leaderboard 200 170 I'm
out of confetti land 8 minutes the only
thing that can save me the only thing
that can save me is you know what is you
know what hook the night hook the bait a
quick castle Bishop check I'll go king
f2 maybe is the knight really gonna go
there there's gonna be pressure on this
pawn I got to get rid of that night
maybe h4 h5 stuff can I get an h4 h5
let's try it and take my knight okay
castle okay now dark square weaknesses
maybe I could work on that Oh drop
tonight where's the quick win I need a
quick win it's not happening it is
definitely not happening dark squares
where are you at Bishop g5 the pawn
pushes hit this and then take and then
Bishop f6 I'm on the rook get developed
here castle pretty sure I could just do
this no matter what
I'm gonna take my knight wants to jump
in right here and then get that h7 pod
and then promote age 7 and then promote
I can't be defended I think now okay
they resign back to tournament 200 190
160 how much times seven minutes and
change come on let's go down to the wire
down to the wire let's go each pawn take
him he's free actually he really is free
he really is but maybe I could start
pushing him around here we go he's got
to find a new home he might be dead if
he goes there he's dead it's a dead
night dead night pawn push kill the
bishop let's do this first
and it's take how are they gonna
recapture okay right here if I did that
there's Bishop takes maybe although I
think I would have something for that
pawn push next maybe I should have done
that sooner ah
this seems is very appealing to do this
then jump my knight right in here right
in here can I get that light square I
want to get back here with my queen
making one thread making one come on yes
yes yes that was kind of quick back to
tournament 220 190 180 I'm 40 points out
oh man oh I didn't mean to do that
f4 8f 3v3 Bishop b2 my moves are my
moves are definitely sticking here my
computers has been running hot at the
beginning since the start of the stream
really really uh
really really tough human are you
creating excuses again where's that mate
I'm on the night this has to be right
right but to check where is the mate
though right here check check check
check mate is that me
that's me back to tournament that worked
out to twenty to ten 200 Oh
anything could happen I'm in confetti
land but I'm close to being not in
confetti land c5 c5 fourth place
fourth place is the first not confetti
loser what am I saying I don't even know
what I just said you know I was getting
at though right you don't get confetti
for fourth place that was a better way
to say it no confetti for fourth place
castle power of suggestion
check sneak my king there let's go here
I should just grab that pond take my
knight take this
oh I didn't want to have to trade like
that I should have just defended this
they're gonna see that the record set
yes they are
ah I was looking for tricks there I'm
always looking for tricks aren't I check
pins I should have just taken it I guess
this is still okay it's a pig are they
gonna resign they might resign they
resigned back to tournament two twenty
two forty two thirty two twenty it's
free minutes and change I need to win
two more games somehow somehow can I get
two more games can I get a quick one
sneaky sneaking this everywhere I got to
do a pawn push
let's try this not working somehow let's
back up if I don't watch I'll be a dead
man soon what does that move even do
what does that move even do oh man
okay they're hanging on to that they're
hanging on to everything oh then out
there to get it written it back
okay okay okay wait let's do this I want
to get rid of the dark square bishop
just can't be easy can it can't be easy
can it
oh we're not Bishop Ron Bishop move move
move
right here I think where's there a check
oh the Queen's guarding that what a
sneaky move right there let's take this
and then I don't have anything pawn
takes I got to do this you're gonna see
I don't have eight seconds ah man gonna
take that
what's my clock situation it's never
good Forks tricky Knight tricky Knight
tricky Knight tricky night there's a
counter fork though counter fork it
wasn't played still not being played
take this can I get this night oh
they're not taken I don't have any time
oh man I don't have any time
oh my god they forfeit that time I'd
point one seconds home to 6250 oh man oh
man sorry for getting loud you know how
it is you know how it is come on I need
a win minute twenty four how do I
regroup I'm going blind now forget about
uh oh man I don't know how how did that
happen give me that gimme a gimme gimme
Siberian stuff fishing pole everywhere
gimme no I want to remove that night yes
yes yes come on resign are they gonna
resign are they a quick resigner come on
gimme gimme gimme gimme mate 57
if I move really quick I might get them
give me this uh get out of there come on
back for me come on open this file up
move Knight move Knight move Knight
power of suggestion oh they're gonna
close it up
I gotta go quick oh that Knights gonna
kill me now no no no
come on take my rope take my rope take
my rope take my rope actually I don't
have made if they do that I can all
anymore
oh no no checks oh man
where are the maids I need mates and
they're not there what does that even do
I should probably take this night ah no
I'm in trouble double-check this isn't
gonna end I might be getting mated I
can't get another one I'm in so much
trouble
oh it's not happening uh third place
confetti I was so close to trying to
sneak another one in there ah 290 270
240 I was lucky to get third ah I wonder
mattered oh he can't so excited about
even if I got 20 more it didn't matter
290 270 240 4th place was closed as well
that was one of the tightest games 238
good games ah I'll take the confetti and
go to the next tournament